he's the only main character who doesn't
want the wish and all he really wants is
just companionship and friends I wish I
had a family like this Harvey gam brings
so much comedy to this character but he
also brings so much heart oh I was just
buying some time for a team a friendship
I always put a little bit of myself into
all the characters that I've played I
really enjoy diving into the idea of
this positive energy all the time if you
meet Harvey he is just the sweetest
kindest funniest person so it was easy
to get into the role of burrito with him
you know early on prito was very chatty
he constantly talked and Harvey
discovered that in order to really tap
into who perito was he cares about
others and so he listens he's so
naturally you know Charming when he's
not trying sometimes you don't need to
try to to just be your authentic
cuteness let's talk
I'd rather eat